-We don't always have
enough time
to cover all of the recent news,
so here to recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys,
things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
the midterms were last week,
and the whole nation
was like, what?!
But then the red wave
didn't come,
and we were like, what?
The whole thing was bananas.
Okay, so,
Marjorie Taylor Greene won,
and I was like, what?
Then Stacey Abrams lost,
And then the race between
Raphael Warnock
and Herschel Walker
was too close to call,
and I was like, wha-a-a-a-a-at?
For the first time, I was like,
maybe there is voter fraud,
because there is no way someone
would want to give this man
an ounce of power.
If you put this man
in charge of Georgia,
he's only gonna get it pregnant,
take it to another state,
and get it an abortion.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no! [ Gasps ]
I'm too late!
Ohh!
That's at least six months,
right there.
And then even though she's the
one who made him famous,
Oprah said to not vote
for Dr. Oz,
and I was like [laughing] what?
Girl, she created him,
and then he lost his mind,
so she had to stop him.
So, remember,
don't call him Winfrey.
Call him Winfrey's monster.
[ Laughter ]
Then I found out that
25-year-old Maxwell Frost
got elected to Congress,
and I was like, "Go ahead,
Gen Z, what-what!"
And he was like, "No one says
what-what anymore."
And I was like,
"Okay, dang, children."
Then I heard the GOP is
turning away from Trump,
and I was like, what!
But then I found out that
they're turning towards
Ron DeSantis,
and I was like...what?
Ron DeSantis is the new face
of the GOP?
Let me get this straight.
You went from this face
to this face?
You're bad at faces.
Then -- and this is real --
the United Nations
Climate Change Conference
ran out of food and water.
[ Laughing ]
I was like, what?
You know damn well
that is too on the nose.
That is like a Taco Bell
conference
running out of farts.
So then I learned that someone
won $2 billion in the lottery,
and I was like, what?!
Man, if I won $2 billion,
I would be out of here.
Between you and me,
it's terrible here.
[ Laughter ]
My boss is so needy.
-Hey, that's not nice.
-Not you!
Seth, you're one cool dude.
-Aw, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Sighs ]
Then, the Astros won
the World Series,
and I was like, what?!
You mean to tell me
the dog from "The Jetsons"
won the World Series?
And then I found out that
the Astros are a sports team.
Now, which sport --
that's none of my business.
So, then I read that
a cruise ship docked in Sydney
had 800 people with COVID on it,
and I was like, what?
Only 800?
A cruise ship without COVID
is like a Taco Bell
without farts.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I'm just kidding.
I love Taco Bell,
and I can prove it.
[ Fart sound ]
[ Laughter ]
So then...
[ Laughter continues ]
-The script said
"tiny fart noise."
[ Laughter ]
-But I had -- I had had
too much Taco Bell,
so it became
something different.
So, then I read that
Elon Musk bought Twitter,
and I was like, "What?
This is gonna be bad!"
But then I read he was gonna
make people pay
for blue check marks,
and I was like, "What?
This is gonna be hilarious."
And sure enough,
people bought blue checks,
and then they posed as famous
people and companies and stuff.
It was great.
I saw a fake Nintendo account
tweet Mario giving the finger,
and I was like, what?
Then I saw a fake
O.J. Simpson account saying,
"Not gonna lie,
I did that [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, what?
But then there was
the best one of all.
This is the funniest thing
I ever read.
Someone started a fake
American Girl doll account
and posted the single best tweet
of all time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] I saw that...
I saw that and I was like,
"That's what
I have been saying!"
Little white children get
these dolls and are like,
"Will the carriage bring me
'round to the ball?
Will I make friends
at boarding school?"
And then a Black girl buys
this doll, and it's like,
"Will I get caught and taken
back to the plantation?"
[ Laughter ]
When it comes to
American Girl dolls,
I have always been
and forever will be
like, what?
Then I saw this clip
of Kamala Harris.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I was like, what?
What are you -- what?
And then I saw this clip.
-Who doesn't love
a yellow school bus, right?
Can you raise your hand if you
love a yellow school bus, right?
Just -- there's something
about the -- and most of us --
many of us went to school
on the yellow school bus, right?
-And I was like, what?
Do you need some -- like, what?
Like, why is -- what?
But then I saw this.
-I love Venn diagrams.
[ Laughs ]
I really do.
I love Venn diagrams.
It's just something about those
three circles and the analysis
about where there is
the intersection, right?
Yeah, I see people, and you
agree with me, right?
-I was like, what?!
Why is no one
trying to save her?
But then I remembered
she said this.
-Under a Biden/Harris
administration,
we will decriminalize
the use of marijuana.
-And I was like,
man, she's fine.
This has been "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]